[Música]
supongo que os sorprenderá ver a un
individuo adulto y serio o al menos en
apariencia
arrastrando un neumático por el
escenario
pero imaginad lo que debían pensar los
vecinos de la liana mi pueblo
cuando me veían hacer esto mismo a las 4
de la madrugada
la policía local también se sorprendía
porque ellos lo hacían partiéndose de
risa
me conocen y la cosa quedaba ahí la
guardia civil no tiene tanto sentido del
humor
ellos se quedaban siempre muy serios
dentro del coche sin bajar las
ventanillas ni decir nada mirándome muy
fijamente de arriba a abajo como
pensándose si llevarme al cuartelillo o
dejarme suelto y no les culpo porque ver
a un señor a las tantas de la noche
con pinta de haberse escapado de sé lo
que hicisteis el último verano
arrastrando dos ruedas pues sorprendería
a cualquiera
pero es que en los últimos años me he
visto en la necesidad de entrenarme para
arrastrar grandes cargas
que además puede ser más peligroso de lo
que puede parecer porque cuando andas
por el borde de una acequia como se
caiga una rueda de atrás va la otra y
detrás va la bestia de carga creyendo
que me ha pasado dos veces luego además
en mi pueblo cada vez que aparece un
neumático por ahí tirado pues me llegan
un montón de mensajes por un lado pues
por si lo he perdido yo y por otro lado
pues me interesa quedarme no
si además trasladamos este entrenamiento
a la montaña te cruzas con gente y
siempre hay alguien que tiene que
decirte algo que se ha pinchado que si
te has dejado el coche arriba porque se
ha averiado y lo estás bajando a piezas
gente muy ocurrente por el mundo
pero bueno la cuestión que me trae hoy
aquí es dar respuesta a qué es aquello
intangible que diferencia a un espécimen
como yo de una persona digamos normal
pero para ello os tengo que poner
primero brevemente en antecedentes
desde mi más tierna infancia me he
dedicado a practicar deporte todo tipo
de deportes me ha interesado siempre
todo lo que se ha puesto delante de mí
crecía haciendo atletismo
luego vino la montaña y todos los
deportes que conlleva
alpinismo esquí escalada la montaña se
convirtió en el centro de mi vida
hasta que sucedió un hecho que sacudió
los cimientos de mi existencia tal y
como lo había conocido hasta aquel
momento y cambió radicalmente mi vida un
hecho que primero me llamó papi
y luego papá
y ya más mayor padre y organismo
pluricelular progenitor y os juro que
esto es totalmente cierto
tuve que dedicarme a otros deportes
empecé a hacer triatlón ciclismo
natación carreras de montaña cada vez
más distancias más largas hasta que
descubrí el mundo de las carreras de
ultradistancia árticas que son como su
propio nombre indica carreras muy largas
de cientos de kilómetros las hay de
hasta 1600
que se desarrollan en territorios
árticos
inhóspitos desolados deshabitados en
pleno invierno a temperaturas en algunos
casos por debajo de los 50 grados y en
los que tienes que arrastrar un trineo
con todo lo necesario para poder
sobrevivir
en algunas de estas carreras el
organizador para poder inscribirte
te graba a través de una
videoconferencia te hace una entrevista
y te graba reconociendo que eres
consciente de que puedes llegar a sufrir
daños o incluso morir durante la carrera
además te advierten que en caso de
necesidad pueden tardar horas e incluso
días en llegar hasta el sitio en el que
estás con lo cual habrás de resolver
todos los problemas por ti mismo y
créeme que esa temperatura hay muy poco
tiempo para resolver los problemas
en una ocasión entré en hipotermia
intentando hacer funcionar un hornillo
entré en pánico porque estuve a punto de
perder el conocimiento y estuve cerquita
de salir corriendo abandonando todo mi
equipo para buscar ayudar menos mal que
respire hondo recapacité y encendí
rápidamente un fuego con el que entre en
calor en pocos minutos
y gracias a no haber tomado la otra
decisión hoy estoy aquí contamos esta
historia además ha habido gente que
practicando estas carreras pues ha
perdido dedos manos e incluso las
piernas yo mismo hace unos años tuve
congelaciones en los dedos de una mano y
dicho todo esto retomó la cuestión que
me ha traído aquí y es dar respuesta a
qué diferencia a un pájaro como yo de la
masa sensata de la humanidad
así a priori se me ocurre pues que este
señor no sea yo si hubiera podido dar
algún que otro golpe de más en la cabeza
en su infancia pero voy a rechazarlo por
dos motivos el primero porque he sido y
respuesta tan rápido me habría acabado
me tocará bajarme del escenario y
sinceramente me apetece tener mis diez
minutos de gloria al completo y el
segundo y no menos importante porque en
mi vida de adultos ayudándome golpes en
la cabeza una y otra vez y no parece
afectar demasiado a mi comportamiento
descartado este tema me planteo otro que
sería pues pensar que yo estoy lo que en
términos médicos se definiría como una
cabra como un cencerro como la trompeta
etcétera etcétera
y a este respecto me vais a permitir que
os cuente otra historia
hace años me encontraba entrenando una
noche como siempre arrastrando mis
ruedas bajo una impresionante luna llena
impresionante
y tuve una epifanía allí bajo aquella
luna llena
casi me pongo a aullar
me di cuenta de que yo era la única
persona cuerda del mundo y que vosotros
la que el resto de la humanidad
durmiendo plácidamente en vuestras camas
erais los que estabais locos llamando el
lunático
y en este caso con fundamento pero la
locura y la cordura son dos términos muy
relativos y como dicen que una imagen
vale más que mil palabras voy a dejar
que éstas hablen por mí para intentar
convencer os de si realmente una persona
está tan loca por querer vivir
semejantes experiencias
apartado el tema de los golpes en la
cabeza y cuestionable salud mental
pregunté a un amigo el cual me contestó
que tal vez la diferencia es que yo era
un yonki de lo imposible
puede ser y a este respecto me vais a
permitir que os cuente otra anécdota
el color es el club donde hago mi
preparación física y por el que compito
y hace unos años se compartía en redes
sociales la noticia de la próxima
organización de una carreta que
consistía en correr desde españa
atravesando europa
cruzar el mar báltico nadando
a través a finlandia rusia siberia hasta
el lago baikal
al norte de mongolia 5000 kilómetros de
pura locura
como un poseso y desesperado me puse a
buscar información inmediatamente
preguntando a todo el mundo
nadie contexto y días después me dirigí
a entrenar alcohol donde mis compañeros
esperaban partiéndose de risa porque de
las 100 personas que había en el grupo
era el único que no se había dado cuenta
que la noticia se había publicado el 28
de diciembre
sí reconozco que soy un yonki duele
imposible pero muchos de vosotros
también os marcáis efectos objetivos
que no son tanto metas como si caminos
proyectos que nos ayudan a tener
motivación para vivir y para disfrutar
del día a día con lo cual puede que yo
lo haga a otra escala pero
no considero que sea la diferencia
principal
e
descartado el golpe en la cabeza a la
salud mental o mi adicción a los retos
imposibles
pregunte a la gente pues qué más tiempo
lleva aguantando me como es mi familia
mi padre lo tiene claro el golpe en la
cabeza pero el que me quiere darle para
que me esté quieto de una vez
mi hermana al preguntarle respondió con
otra pregunta
y tú cual quieres que es esa diferencia
es psicóloga como habréis supuesto
la respuesta que más me sorprendió fuera
de mi mejor amiga mi mujer
que a estas alturas muchos de vosotros
pensaréis que se ha ganado el cielo unas
cuantas veces que respondió sin pensarlo
e inmediatamente la pasión con la que
vive es la vida
llegados a este punto casi cabría pensar
que no existe esa diferencia si te
descuidas hasta si la persona más normal
de esta sala
si acaso
así que puede que sea más consciente que
la mayoría de la gente de lo efímero de
la vida y de que hay que vivirla de que
hay que vivirla como si cada día fuera
el último no estoy diciendo que todo el
mundo se tenga que poner a correr la
pegas árticas ni hacer alpinismo y
saltar en paracaídas ni jugar al parchís
en el ala de un avión en vuelo
pero sí que debemos atrevernos a cometer
nuestros sueños por imposibles o
difíciles que parezcan
y procurar no dejarlos para un futuro
muy lejano pensando que siempre podremos
cumplirlos porque si hay alguna
diferencia
que yo he visto que sí que sí que hay
entre yo y la mayoría de las personas es
que donde otros se preguntan por qué
yo siempre me pregunto por qué no muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]